somebody sent this to me and it said
childhood can last until you're 40.
no it can't it shouldn't
no
but let's read a little bit dr brenna
hassett an anthropologist at university
college london told an audience and i'm
going to skip down it's not even
necessarily about being a parent it's
just about sort of how you're
interacting with your society or culture
but i would say pretty firmly that
there's probably around 40 for me which
is longer than a lot of people that's
where childhood ended 40 years old
okay i talk a lot about the baby
vacation
of america this is in london but we can
talk about the babification of the world
parents
don't do this
i remember when we had conversations
about obamacare and i was one of the
people
you're you're one of the bad guys
because i was saying okay you can keep
your kids on your insurance till they're
26 that's not a kid
that's an adult and that's a bad message
let your kid
figure it out
a little bit of tough love that's not to
say
that parents shouldn't you know if
parents you know buy a gift for their
kids great if parents save money for
their kids and say hey we save this for
you we want to help you out with this or
that great i have parents that are
always like what can we do is there
anything we can do my parents don't have
a lot of money but they
can we babysit hartley i'm not talking
about that i'm talking about treating
your child like a baby
until they're 40 years old that's a
problem remember that conversation about
obamacare 26 years old and people were
having that conversation calling those
26 year old children you know my dad
said to me i'll never forget this
conversation
i got out of grad school and i decided
that i had always wanted to be an actor
i didn't do it when i was younger
because i was too shy and i was like i'm
gonna go float around i'm gonna do this
i need to feel it out
the sad part of the story is i still
didn't feel it out because i got chicken
again
can you imagine twice in your life to
become a chicken so sad not good biela
anyway i remember saying to my dad in
order for me to do this i'm worried i'm
not gonna have medical insurance
so can you um can you figure out a way
like can your company put me on and he
looked at me and he was like i'll forget
he was like
no
and i was like that felt cold you know
that felt real cold but my dad was like
you want to do this
you have to figure it out
you have to figure this out
and what i wound up doing was
taking some jobs i i had to hustle more
to figure it out
but that lesson was so impactful to me
because ultimately
it was good
he he in that moment
gave me a great compliment he said
you're an adult
i raised you you're capable you got this
you want this
go get it
and that's what i did
now had i been able to lean on him and
say oh let me stay on the insurance a
couple more years a couple more years
couple more years maybe i wouldn't have
gotten that second job
maybe i wouldn't have hustled so much
maybe i wouldn't have uh mastered time
management the way that i did maybe i
wouldn't have gotten into teaching and
figured out a whole bunch of stuff about
myself there maybe i wouldn't be here
but that was essential in that moment
that he treated me like a 20 you know
whatever year old i think i was 20
i think it was 23.
he didn't treat me like 16 year old
because i was 16. and i was trying to do
big girl things and he was saying you
want to do big girl things then you got
to act like a big girl so thank you for
that
um again i'm not saying that parents you
know
can't mail you a birthday card or they
save up money for you and they can't say
listen we worked really hard we say this
for you we want you to have that's not
what i'm saying what i'm saying is in
some of those pivotal moments where
you're young and you're impressionable
it's up to your parents to decide
they're going to treat you like a child
or are they going to treat you like the
adult that you are
so this stuff here again the baby
vacation
i titled this episode last night
corruption of kids because i just feel
like the mistakes that are being made
with respect to adults okay
we've been raised right but the mistakes
that are that are happening with respect
to kids i don't care if it's treating
them like babies for way too long and
they sleep on the couch and they get
lazy and they don't figure out how to
fend for themselves and they don't get
that spark of entrepreneurship because
they can be lazy
and they don't have to or we're talking
about a pfizer trial or we're talking
about you know let's have a drag queen
in every school we'll get to that
tomorrow um i don't care what it is kids
are being sacrificed right now
and they're suffering
they're suffering and we can do
something about it we as adults it's our
job they're not gonna know to ask the
tough questions about a vaccine trial
they're not going to know
to be proactive and and be involved in
the school board and make sure that's
not trickling down into the classrooms
they're not they're not raising
themselves we're raising them so if they
want to be
you know spoiled they're going to try to
get away with what they you know kids we
all try to get away with what we can get
away with so adults
we need a wake-up call this is getting
really serious
and if you i don't care where you are on
the ideological spectrum i don't care
i don't care we all love our kids
my message to you today is ask questions
whatever you think the answer is make
sure that's an answer you're comfortable
with
go up to your kid's school see what's
going on there make sure you're
comfortable and if you're not open your
mouth and if you open your mouth and it
doesn't work pull them out figure
something else out
it's our job to be parents and if we're
not parents the kids suffer if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
you